[Music]
indigenous people across Brazil once
more facing threats to their survival
for two years they've been urging the
Supreme Court to take action and confirm
their rights to ancestral lands tribal
leaders warning Supreme Court president
josebe that uncertainty has bred
violence
take care of us we can't sleep in peace
knowing that our constitutional rights
are being questioned and that we're at
the mercy of Invaders who grab our lands
at any cost
the issue at stake is a landmark case
establishing a time frame to limit the
number of indigenous reserves in Brazil
if approved only tribes living on their
territories at the time Brazil enacted
its constitution in 1988 can claim them
yes
we have a problem with that date before
1988 many indigenous peoples were forced
out of their territories at gunpoint
Brazil was a military dictatorship and
they had no means to fight for their
rights if the 1988 time frame is
established their land claims and
hundreds of others will be annult
but even if the justices rule in their
favor Brazil's indigenous peoples are
facing a still greater threat this time
from the conservative dominated Congress
wonderful Farm Lobby is pushing for a
bill that will open protected indigenous
territories to commercial activities
such as logging and farming it also
allows the government to reclaim
existing reserves
environmentalists say that this
legislation not only puts the survival
of hundreds of tribes in danger but also
that of the Amazon rainforest and with
the clear possibility of conflicting
rulings from each branch of the
government there's uncertainty on both
sides of the debate about exactly what
land rights in Brazil will mean in
practice
Rio de Janeiro
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera